♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
WHITECOAT WASTE PROFIT HAS JUST
FOUND THAT A LAB IN NORTH AFRICA
INFECTED DOZENS OF BEAGLES WITH
DISEASE CAUSING PARASITES.
THIS RESEARCH WAS FUNDED BY
TONY FAUCI'S NIH WHICH SENT A
$375 GRANT TO THE LAB.
ACCORDING TO THE NONPROFIT THE
MONEY WENT TO DRUGGING BEAGLES,
LOCKING THEIR HEADS AND MESH
CAGES FULL OF HUNGRY SAND FLIES
US OF THE INSECTS COULD EAT THEM
ALIVE.
THAT IS DISGUSTING AND THE
PEOPLE WHO FUNDED IT SHOULD BE
SUBMITTED TO THAT TO SEE HOW
THEY LIKE IT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TODAY
DEFENDED IT.
A COLUMNIST THERE WILL DEFEND
NEARLY ANYTHING.
IT WAS HIS JOB TO TAKE ONE FOR
THE TEAM SO HE WROTE A
STRAIGHT-FACED ARTICLE THAT
DEFENDING THIS IS SOMEHOW
IMMORAL.
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AT PETA
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS SO OFFENSIVE THAT IT IS
HARD TO EVEN TALK ABOUT IT ON TV
BUT I WANT TO LEAVE OPEN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT MAYBE THERE IS
SOME REASON WE HAD TO TORTURE
DOGS TO DEATH?
GIVE US YOUR VIEW.
>> THERE IS NO REASON FOR THE
DISGRACE THAT THIS EXPERIMENT IS
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IT IS JUST
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG OF WHAT
IS GOING ON AT NIH.
NIH BUYS THOUSANDS OF DOGS, THEY
SUBJECT THEM TO EXPERIMENTS THAT
ONLY FREDDY KRUEGER COULD THINK
UP AND ALL OF THIS HAS TO
CHANGE.
THE LAST TIME I WAS ON HERE WITH
YOU, I SAID THAT NIH DIRECTOR
FRANCIS COLLINS NEEDS TO GO.
UNFORTUNATELY SINCE THEN HE HAS
ANNOUNCED HIS RESIGNATION.
NOW THE REST OF THE NIH
DIRECTOR'S NEED TO GO TOO.
>> Tucker: THAT IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
MY SENSE FROM READING A LOT
ABOUT THIS IS MANY OF THESE
TORTURE SESSIONS, THEY ARE NOT
EVEN EXPERIMENTS, THEY ARE
TORTURING ANIMALS WHO CAN'T HELP
THEMSELVES, THIS IS DRIVEN BY
FUNDING.
THERE IS MONEY AVAILABLE TO THE
EXPERIMENT TAKES PLACE BUT IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HELP SCIENCE
OR ANY PEOPLE, IT'S JUST, THEY
NEED TO SPEND THE MONEY.
>> THAT IS WHAT THEY KNOW AND
THEY SPENT $19 BILLION EVERY
YEAR ON ANIMAL EXPERIMENTS EVEN
THOUGH WE KNOW THESE EXPERIMENTS
ARE NOT GOING TO FIND CURES AND
TREATMENTS FOR HUMAN BEINGS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE OTHER
LABORATORIES, RIGHT INSIDE NIH'S
LABORATORY IN MARYLAND,
ELIZABETH MURRAY AS WE EXPOSED
LAST YEAR, BRAIN DAMAGE AS
MONKEYS AND THEN TRIES TO
FRIGHTEN THEM IN TINY CAGES WITH
PLASTIC SNAKES AND SPIDERS.
THIS KIND OF EXPERIMENTATION
GOES ON ALL THE TIME.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PRIMATE
CENTER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON, THEY ARE FULL BODY
IRRADIATING MONKEYS, DESTROYING
THEIR IMMUNE SYSTEMS COMPLETELY
AND WE ARE ALL PAYING FOR THIS.
THERE IS NO REASON TO DO IT, IT
NEEDS TO STOP.
>> Tucker: I FEEL SICK JUST
HEARING THESE STORIES.
WHY WOULD ANYBODY, YOU SEE
PEOPLE REFLEXIVELY DEFEND THE
STUFF, IT'S SCIENCE.
ITS CRUELTY, IT'S NOT SCIENCE,
BUT WHY WOULD ANYONE DEFEND
THIS?
>> DEFENDING THE STATUS QUO
SEEMS TO BE THE DEFAULT POSITION
OF MOST PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT HOW WE PROGRESS AS A
SOCIETY AND WE HAVE TO GET NIH
TO COME TO TERMS WITH THIS AND
REMEMBER THEIR CONSTITUENCY IS
NOT THE ANNUAL EXPERIMENTERS,
WITH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
>> Tucker: THAT SEEMS TO BE
THE DEFAULT POSITION FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE, I DO THINK